Kathy is in Orlando to start off this
segment hi Kathy how are you hi I'm fine
thank you thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I was hoping you could
help give me some some financial advice
during difficult marital times do you
have any is it any different than
regular marital times like if having
difficulties like say your husband has a
girlfriend yeah that'd be pretty
difficult so here this marriage is this
marriage going to end I am it depends on
him
really you're pretty forgiving I'm
really struggling well he says they're
just friends you know when did you
discover you actually he told me about
it he's like oh I'm just going well the
first encounter or visit with the
ex-girlfriends actually his
ex-girlfriend from 25 years ago he
reconnected with her and no not even now
it's just I I don't know if it's that
he's going through a midlife crisis I
don't know what's going on you need to
say it you know darling I your brain
your brain jumbled up oh no no I there's
a murder to be committed here you've got
you need to get some guidance because
you're trying to be sweet and you're
trying to believe it and yet your brain
you in your heart but your brain is
telling you this guy's cheating on you
yeah sleepovers are cool thing I've said
this and he continued again just this
month okay nothing's happening oh yeah
darling you are sweet you're so nice
okay no adults don't do sleepovers with
people they're not married to of the
opposite sex okay that is not normal
that's okay you need to go see a
counselor and you need to go see a
divorce attorney and then you need to
decide which one you're going to use but
Baba needs game is up with Baba here
he's he's played that a man yours yeah
so darling the way you prepare
financially and I'm so sorry you're
going through this is you
hold on I'm gonna talk to you when I
come back this is the Dave Ramsey show
talking with Kathy in Orlando and I had
to get up off the floor to give her a
proper answer she's her husband has a
reconnected with his old girlfriend from
26 years ago he's doing sleepovers with
the old girlfriend says nothing's going
on and she's trying to figure out how to
prepare in a bad marriage situation
financially is that a fair summary what
you told me darling yes okay how long
have you been married 18 years I'm sorry
okay well let me just from an outside
perspective tell you what the 12 million
people listening to me right now
are all thinking okay normal people that
are married do not have sleepovers with
the opposite sex ever
in any circumstances that they are not
married to okay that's just not
acceptable social behavior it's nuts I
know this is nuts and the fact that he
would try to play it off on that says
that he has a level of BS in his life
that is unbelievable okay so he's off
the ranch kiddo is what I'm saying
and I'm trying to be kind to you because
you're hurting and you're sad and I
don't blame you but you need to have the
the thing that's rising up inside of
your throat validated because you have
to have that unless you have absolutely
no self-esteem at all you have to be
going this is nuts
so you need somebody outside to say this
is nuts this is nuts I just said it okay
I want you to hear that really loud and
clear if I suggested to Sharon Ramsey
that I was going to sleep over with
someone of the opposite sex I would not
have the equipment to do so by the time
I left the house okay you follow me
that's how this that's how that works in
the normal world all right and so it's
just home unbelievable so you are you
guys are are you in a church at all no
I'm not all right do you have access to
someone that can recommend to you a good
solid marriage counselor that can walk
you through the tough decisions and
conversations that your
have you need to get someone in you need
to get someone in your corner that way
okay I have a call-out he has refused to
go with me so I work all right now yeah
he's got this thing yeah he doesn't look
here well let me just tell you 12
million people just ganged up on him all
right they're all listening to me
they're all going he's nuts all right he
just got ganged up on too late and he
deserves it because he's completely out
of line listen if you want to divorce
your wife and then go sleep around we
can discuss that I don't like that
that's a bad idea but this is ABS this
con this guy's trying to run on you is
just it's ludicrous it really says he
thinks you're stupid is really what it
is
I mean anybody that would believe this
is stupid and he thinks that about you
so you need to get a good counselor then
the second thing you've got to get a
today you've got to get with a counselor
and you've got to get with a good
divorce attorney I'm not saying you 100%
are going to go through a divorce
that'll be your decision but you need to
have the information to know what it
looks like because information in the
middle of high stress scenarios which
you're in helps you have power to make
good decisions
it's ugly Dave I've called a lawyer and
in the state I live in it's 50/50 no
matter what yes all three doesn't matter
no it doesn't follow the hard work I
don't know one who does the budget I'm
the one who's done all the planning yeah
he gives you that's the way it is in
most states now okay and so that that
part's ugly but it's uglier to stay in
an untenable situation and I'm not
suggesting it's over but but it probably
is statistically speaking I mean if you
turn this around you beat the odds so to
speak right so you go get some
counselors to guide you through it now
what the attorney has taught you then is
this that I've got a friend that does
divorce recovery work all the time and
she has a wonderful saying it's not a
wonderful thing it's an accurate saying
divorce turns a marriage into a business
transaction and so it's now down to who
gets what and when and access to kids or
whatever you get children no no kids
okay that part's a little cleaner but
it's just a matter of giving up the
stuff and it becomes a business
that is laced in anger and broken hearts
and visceral emotions but it's still a
business negotiation at the end of the
day and so here's the interesting thing
and I will throw this in if this is the
track he decides to go on and if it ends
your marriage he's gonna want out
quickly and if I were negotiating on
your side I would make that cost him
he's going to give up some stuff in
order for you to make this quick
I would drag it out and make it painful
for a while just because I'm that kind
of guy so I mean I'm serious
because it sounds like the way you
described that a minute ago there's some
assets involved they're pretty serious
not like - we don't have any debt which
is a huge thing that's good and house is
paid off that's putting yeah in other
words the court says you get 50 percent
but you can negotiate more than that in
a settlement in Florida but the divorce
wait I need a better to find a better
lawyer
she was really cruel about it and like
you'll discover because I put him
through school and of course you know
the last part of it anyway the last yeah
yeah what you what you want when you've
got a divorce lawyers you want someone
that's kind of mean that you don't even
really like them because this is a it's
a war it's a war we're going to war if
you go that way
and I kind of think you're going to I'm
not I'm not telling you that's what you
have to do but I am telling you we're
not nobody is believing this BS line of
his okay and so you need to get with a
counselor that keeps you in between the
ditches and lets you remind you that you
are saying and he is not with this
portion of the discussion and then you
need an attorney over here that's giving
you advice on how to handle the money
transactions and how to begin to
negotiate the separation and when to
throw him out and so on and you know all
of that but your counselor will lead you
through a series of if they're a strong
counselor a series
of discussions that says okay you know
we can continue to be married but these
are the rules if we're going to continue
to be married and if he doesn't want to
go along with those rules then then
we're not going to be married and you
have to set out some ultimatums for your
sanity otherwise you're the crazy one
and you're not yeah yeah it makes me
feel like I'm the one who's like normal
I'm like well no this is not normal this
is not normal it never happened in 17
years I guess no it's just not normal
it doesn't matter how long it's been
it's just not normal normal people don't
do this crap okay I mean if you if
there's all kinds of weird stuff out
there that's perverted and all that but
I'm talking about normal people that are
all in there or not you know I just you
know and either you're gonna calm
something crazy that's crazy or you are
crazy there's really no in-between and
so you have to kind of keep somebody in
your corner while you're in these high
stress scenarios that give you
information on the legal side and give
you information on the emotional
psychological and spiritual side to
guide you through this so that you can
stay so you make solid good decisions
that you don't regret later that you
weren't too harsh but you were tough and
you weren't you weren't angry and bitter
but you allowed yourself to feel the
emotions that are real okay
okay and you just kind of somebody walk
with you honey and and that's that's the
thing and I'm so sorry you're going
through this but I just want to validate
some of those things that you're
thinking are absolutely true the reason
I brought up Facebook is is there's this
ridiculous statistic that something like
20 to 30% of divorces have a Facebook
contact to an old flame involved and so
there's this tremendous thing and she
said this one wasn't but um there's this
tremendous problem out there people
looking up the old flame oh I wonder
what she looks like now most the time
you look her up and you're going oh I
did good are you looking up and you went
oh really son back up from the table
this is what happens most the time when
you look up an old flame right or they
look me up they go Howard all his hair
go oh
so but sometimes I reconnect and we've
had more than one set of friends lose
their marriage to the reconnect to the
old flame thing and add y'all at deal ah
oh I'm not calling Facebook the devil
but the devil lives there like he lives
everywhere so what a sad situation this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show you can do
this you know that really is a message
whether you've got two hundred seventy
thousand dollars in student loan debt or
27 thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000
ending
[Music]